et avec nous pour en parler naoufel ben
rayana el mili en enseignant à sciences
po paris auteur de l ouvrage
france-algérie 50 ans d'histoires
secrètes aux éditions fayard bonjour à
vous merci d'être avec nous demain les
algériens vont fêter les un an du irak
est encore une mobilisation aujourd'hui
53e vendredi est-ce qu'il va falloir
s'attendre là une renouveau de de la
mobilisation est peut-être que renouveau
c'est pas le terme adapté
la mobilisation se poursuit nous sommes
à l'an 1 de la révolution long 1 vient
d'être clôturée et le pouvoir
je crois que le décret au journal
officiel va sortir demain ou après
demain le 22 février sera décrétée
journée nationale si je traduis bien le
mot séjour national de la fusion entre
le peuple et l'armée
le bilan de gaillac
j'irai pas globalement positif ça
rappellerait georges marchais est
positif qu'il y a il n'y a pas eu de
cinquième mandat et les figures les plus
apparentes de systèmes sont aujourd'hui
devant la justice
donc il ya eu un fonctionnement c'est le
peuple qui manifeste sous pression du
peuple
l'armée a mis un terme au cinquième
mandat a mis un terme aux activités
prédatrices d'oligarques et d'hommes
politiques et se poursuit comme un
aiguillon
parce qu'aujourd'hui l'algérie à nouveau
président il sait qu'il est sous
observation lui même il a dit que ce
irak et
et moubarak que je traduirai ça
bienvenue donc c'est une façon de se
parler mais les attentes sont tellement
grande qu'il y a des impatiences et
c'est un processus révolutionnaire parce
que le mois et là que j'aime pas trop je
veux je préfère parler de révolution
mais c'est une révolution qui n'est pas
dans le sens bolchévique le irak à des
attentes énormes ça prendra du temps et
on peut parler de fusion entre l'armée
et le peuple comme vous l'avez vraiment
préciser parce que l'idée du irak des
manifestants qui descendent dans la rue
tous les vendredis justement c'était
d'en finir avec l'ère bouteflika les
caciques du pouvoir aussi c'est pas
forcément le cas aujourd'hui l'élection
elle a été très contestée n'en voulait
pas de cette élection les algériens donc
où l'armée n'a pas été quand même
jusqu'à un soutien unanime vis-à-vis du
peuple
non il y à des figures au sein du
commandement militaire qui était
clivante j'utilise le passé parce que le
le premier chef des armées est décédé
mais l'armée quand sonic reste très
populaire au niveau de l'armée est aussi
je signale là où on est un an
il n'y a pas eu une balle tirée donc il
ya eu fusion de l'armée reste populaire
et aussi et au delà de la contestation
sur le plan géopolitique avec un millier
de kilomètres de frontière avec la libye
l'armée est la garante sans l'armée il y
aurait une somalisation de l'algérie
donc on peut parler de fusion
quand tu en prends du recul quand on
fait le bilan le bilan est à mettre à
l'actif du peuple mais les procédures
ce n'est pas une justice populaire ce
n'est pas le peuple qui est parti
chercher les oligarques de chez eux pour
les jugés dans des tribunaux populaires
et autres
ensuite c'était la force publique donc
il y a fusion complémentarité et parfois
des antagonismes les agendas ne sont pas
conformes l'agenda du pouvoir n'est pas
encore quand forme avec l'agenda du
peuple l'objectif du irak
un an après justement le début du
mouvement
l'objectif du irak ce c'est bon ça s'est
ténue et mais pendant longtemps c'est
ils dégagent tous
ce n'est pas réaliste aujourd'hui
l'objectif de l axe et la moralisation
de la vie politique et surtout la
démocratie il y aura un premier test le
premier test ça sera les élections
légistatives parce que cette assemblée
nationale va être dissoute elle aura une
mission à remplir discuter la négociable
discuter la nouvelle constitution lors
de la discussion de la même qu'aux sera
diffusée en direct donc on aura des
députés qui vont apprendre être mis sous
observation des législatives pour quand
il n'y a pas d'agenda fixé mais on peut
espérer que tout sera en ordre pour la
rentrée prochaine avant l'été peut-être
et c'est à ce moment là ce sera le test
si on aura il faudrait que le l'un des
résultats de ces cas d'acné eu pas mal
ça sera comment fabriquer un député
honnête ça sera ça le défi
la fabrication des piles est honnête il
faut que sois élu honnêtement et ce sera
les élections transparentes et là il y
aura un test et le nouveau président
abdelmajid teboul est ce qu'il a donné
des signaux forts puisque
on a appris que plusieurs collectifs
citoyens devaient se rassembler n'ont
pas pu le faire faute d'autorisation
légale
qu'est ce qu'il faut en penser qu'elles
sont les signaux aujourd'hui que le
pouvoir actuel donne au peuple algérien
les signaux forts de manière tangible
le président de beaune appelé au
dialogue avec le lac des cygnes efforts
des prises des détenus d'opinion ont été
libérés hélas pas tous et l'autre signal
fort parce que qui n'est pas directement
lié aux irak mais qu'il y ait à
l'algérie c'est le retour de l'algérie
sur la scène internationale pendant sept
ans en avait un président absent et
aujourd'hui il ya ce retour là on compte
sur l'algérie donc il ya des acquis
parce que il y a un an je serai là
j'étais convaincu qu'on aura vous de
filtrage et pourquoi avoir à refuser
ils ont tord et or ont refusé justement
que plusieurs collectifs se réunissent
l'administration je ne sais pas
sincèrement mais l'administration et là
on est dans un cas qu'on juge explosif
c'est le principe de précaution mais
c'est vrai que ça interpelle mais
l'administration
en revanche en revanche ce dont je suis
certain c'est vendredi vont continuer et
ça sera salutaire
et ça sera une forme de dialogue mais
tôt ou tard si ce krach fait apparaître
fait émerger des représentants pour les
prochaines législatives
rien n'interdit de penser qu'il y aura
des éléments de l a qui vont être député
à quel taux n'en sais rien merci
beaucoup à vous naoufel ben rayana
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur arte
france rappelle que vous êtes enseignant
à sciences po paris auteur de l'ouvragé
france-algérie 50 ans d'histoires
secrètes aux éditions fayard